aujourd'hui ici à Lausanne, le
comité exécutif de l'agence mondiale antidopage
a approuvé à l'unanimité la décision
du comité d'examen de la conformité d'
affirmer la non-conformité de l'
agence antidopage russe pour une période de quatre
ans, ce qui entraîne certaines
conséquences ces conséquences ont été
clairement énoncées préalablement à
la réunion afin qu'elles aient été approuvées dans
leur intégralité toutes ces
recommandations ont été approuvées par
le xqo aujourd'hui et un certain nombre de
conditions strictes de réadmission
réintègrent la Russie le moment venu
, c'est donc ce qui a été décidé aujourd'hui
et  c'était une décision unanime
des 12 membres de l'ESCO, cela signifie
que les athlètes russes s'ils le
souhaitent s'ils veulent participer
aux Jeux olympiques ou paralympiques ou
aux divers événements majeurs
répertoriés dans cette recommandation
ils vont devoir ils vont
devoir prouver qu'ils n'ont rien à voir
avec la non-conformité donc ils ont  d
ils n'étaient pas impliqués dans les
stratagèmes de dopage tels que décrits par les rapports de MacLaren,
ils n'étaient en aucune façon affectés
ou avaient leurs échantillons ou données affectés par
cette manipulation ouais Russie La Russie
ne sera pas représentée La Russie ne
sera représentée à aucun de ces  les événements où
leur drapeau ne flottera pas sur la
Fédération de Russie n'auront d'équipe dans aucun
de ces événements